in this final lecture we will first
review the various properties of an ice
markov chain which ensures steady-state
behavior and go over some of the notions
in more details with some examples
providing some insights on how good an
approximation we have when we use
steady-state probabilities to
characterize the behavior of a markov
chain which has run for a long time but
not an infinite amount of time we will
then consider a classical application of
Markov chains which has to do with the
design of a phone system this is a
famous problem which was posed analyzed
and solved by a Danish engineer by the
name of Erlang it was more than 100
years ago when phones just started to
exist but we will see that this
mythology remains relevant to design
similar systems in today's world we will
then make use of all what we have
learned so far in order to calculate
some interesting short-term behaviors of
Markov chains having more than one
recurrent classes we will introduce the
notion of absorbing states and we will
show how to calculate the probability of
ending up in such a state as well as
related quantities such as the expected
time it takes to do so as a classical
example we will look at a gambler
continuously playing a simple game of
chance
say Allah tree until he either
accumulates a given amount of money or
loses all its money both these states
are absorbing what are their
corresponding probabilities after this
lecture you will be able to answer such
questions